after that stark warning from President
Obama after his intervention in the
European Union debate last week his most
likely successor has followed suit
Hillary Clinton has echoed the president
in backing a strong United Kingdom in a
strong European Union leave campaign has
branded the US president a lame duck
after his warning that Britain would be
at the back of the queue for an American
trade deal if he did leave the European
Union well I'm joined out by one of them
the you keep leader Nigel Farage very
good morning morning to you mr. Faraj
well president barack obama's has gone
in and hillary clinton
weighs in that only do you object on the
basis that they should just keep their
noses out in spite of the fact that
they're the most powerful nation on
earth and now the special relationship
with this country well i think you know
if we were to intervene if a british
prime minister was to intervene in a
presidential election america would go
absolutely berserk and say there's
Rutten a ridiculous outside interference
I'd rather he'd said nothing but let's
just analyze what he did say and your
little clip there he said we'd be at the
back of the queue doesn't he look you
know interesting isn't there do you
smell a rat with Q interesting isn't it
Americans don't use the word Q they use
the word lime so he's come over here to
parrot the Downing Street line he's done
it again with the interview yesterday
when he said trade deal could take ten
years I would just put an old Salomon
why not just exaggerate the whole thing
he's he's parroting the Cameron line so
it's not just the political
establishment in Britain clubbing
together it's the global political class
clubbing together but okay I mean Q line
I mean he wouldn't say it whatever the
word is if he didn't believe well no I
mean they just completely they just
concluded a trade deal with Oh mom the
Americans have done a trade deal with
Australia that was signed sealed and
delivered within 10 months you would
have thought that one of their major
trading partners in the world would be
quite important well it's taking so it's
purely political its bridges this is not
about trade this is purely political but
let's take even the ten months I mean
because this is significant we young
know and this is this is fact that
investment decisions are on hold at the
moment until the referendum know that
it's all sorry this is coming from
economic survey so it's your book don't
know in jabal supposably the press have
even even if you negotiate the trade
deal in
months you've still got ten months of us
first things first Deutsche börse have
just bid 20 billion London Stock
Exchange Toyota are investing money avon
are moving their European headquarters
to London there's plenty of investment
still coming into the UK at the moment
the pound is weak do you know what the
pound has been in the bear market since
July 2014 I used to do this for a living
I know about these things
alright and sterling will go lower
regardless of the result you know let's
face it British public finances are not
in a great state all right so that's why
the pound is going down now on the big
questions about we do not have a trade
deal with America at the moment and yet
we do lots of business China doesn't
have a trade deal with the European
Union and yet sells it 300 billion euros
worth of goods every year you don't
actually have to have trade deals to do
business but it's preferable if you do
and remember when we vote to leave we
invoke article 50 of the European
treaties which means for up to two years
our trading relationships are completely
unaffected giving us all the time in the
world to sort out new relationship and
you agree with Boris Johnson lately the
Mayor of London about the president's
background having effect on his view
about the UK of course Boris Johnson
referred to his part Kenyan ancestry and
you've said about Barack Obama because
of his grandfather and Kenya
colonization I don't like what I think I
did it that's the point I've made these
points about Barack Obama for several
years you know it struck me over the
spill in the Gulf the when BP was the
responsible company
Barack Obama kept calling it British
Petroleum and did it in a certain way
but that's the point we think he's an to
the British I don't think he's very Pro
British and because of because I'm a
Kenyan grandfather what the reasons are
frankly don't matter what matters is the
intervention he's made in British
politics was Boris Johnson wrong then
I'm not saying Boris was wrong but I
think if you're seen to be attacking the
man and not the ball then that's not
where we need to be but you've done it
well I've been saying it for some years
does that make a difference what do you
I could just deny my past but but I
can't really do that I've said for some
time that Barack Obama is not a pro
British president but ever frankly that
is not the issue the issue here
is he spouting a line he's saying he
doesn't think the UK should be an
independent sovereign democracy and he's
a man and he's saying but it does matter
miss for us because you know you're
talking about motivation about why I'm
saying it now you've agreed with Boris
Johnson in the past that he has a
certain animus towards 1k because of
Kenya and Cole there is a bigger
motivation and that is with this trip
and with what he said he's guaranteed
his financial future he's done the
bidding of the giant American corporates
who want Britain to stay in the EU why
because they want this TTIP
transatlantic trade and investment
partnership deal done so that the big
American corporates can buy up chunks of
our public services including the
National Health Service that's a bigger
motivation let me let me move this on
into the the overall campaign to leave
of course Boris Johnson in that camp
that got the the official designation do
you think he's messing it up I would say
this we are just over a week into the
campaign proper I think believe campaign
has got two fundamental problems the
first is that it appears that the leave
campaign is just the conservative
cabinet ministers and it's fantastic
we've got six of them on board but if
that's all we see well that's no good
because nearly 75% of the electorate did
not vote conservative in the elections
last year I was on a TV debate on a
radio debate on Friday with Mick cash
who leads the RMT made a very eloquent
left-wing case as to why the EU was
actually bad for workers and bad for
workers living standards I think to win
this referendum you've got a see trade
union voices you've got to see labour
voices you've got to see you get voices
you know we've got to be appealing to a
broader group of people than just the
Tory electorate
the second problem is if we debate
economics and trade we can govern the
circles for weeks and the public will be
none the wiser in my opinion at the end
of it but if we do that that's kind of
defending our goal right because they're
attacking us on this what the remain
camp do not want to talk about is the
fact we have an open door to 508 million
people what they don't want to talk
about is the fact that two of those
murderers in Paris
had come back into Europe using the
Greek islands posing as migrants and
what we as a leave campaign need to do
is to start talking about those issues
which the remain camp will find so there
you are a typical to different you
describe it there you've been sidelined
how frustrated does that make you well
I'll be very frustrated if we lose the
referendum and it's up to those of us
who and I'm one of them it's up to those
of us who the official leave campaign
don't wish to use to go out around the
country and make our own noise and I
will be doing my talking about foreign
political leaders offering support we
heard there your a criticism of Barack
Obama Hillary Clinton of course weighing
in on your side and marine lepen
from the front national apparent she's
coming over in a couple of weeks to
apparently to the UK are you gonna meet
her do you welcome them no I don't think
it's but I don't think it's particular
for I'm not quite sure why she wants to
do it although I mean she's a committed
you're a skeptic and indeed rather
credentialing this isn't it right across
the continent there are now you're a
skeptics on the right like lepen but
equally on the left like the damos and
cereza in Greece and everywhere we're
seeing the massive growth of euro
skeptic parties and of course a Dutch
referendum the other wing that said no
to the Ukraine deal a referendum in
December in Denmark that said no to
European justice and Home Affairs so
there was a big euro skeptic movement
now right across the content but just
marine lepen come if you like or please
don't come what is it what what I don't
think her intervention would help our
side of the debate I'd rather she didn't
come but I mean I've heard some
ridiculous ideas this morning put around
we should banner from entering the
country that clearly would be more
ludicrous okay now tell me about you kit
because you know we've talked about this
before you know win or lose what in the
future for you keep we're hearing you're
talking about rebranding it refashioning
it repositioning it becoming you know a
parallels droid that big real yeah well
i've star party and it's a pretty
interesting
bepi Grillo had a sort of internet guru
called Jan Roberto casalecchio behind
him who died a couple of weeks ago
they're now on thirty percent of the
national opinion polls and they've swept
the youth vote in Italy similarly an
organization called Green Steel in the
Netherlands got nearly half a million
signatures for that referendum that took
place the other week and what I'm seeing
because I'm out around the country every
day because
massive set of elections coming up in a
few weeks times all over the UK and I
keep meeting people between 18 and 30
who are enthusiastic you Clippers were
right behind you make love your videos
we retweet your SOT so though you think
the image is a bit too finely you are
you appearing in a pub with a pint of
old wallop or whatever it is it's not
really appealing to the 18 to 25 is it
what I'm saying the opposite to that I
think I'm meeting them in pubs okay
elsewhere and I'm finding I'm finding
some really enthusiastic support from
this segment of the population and yet
not one of them is considered joining
euchre they just don't think about you
know filling in a form and writing out a
check and sending off 30 just and having
their membership card in their wallet
that generation don't engage with
politics like that now we saw a specimen
of this last year when the Labour Party
said you can join for three quid and
have a vote huge numbers of people
joined the Labour Party I think by going
online by modeling some of what Pepe
grill has done in Italy we could make
you keep a big political party let's do
the parallels here you just said it they
said you didn't say the name modelling
it on what jeremy corbyn's though i'm
sorry for us those no no it's done a
good job I'm saying the Labour Party
attracted hundreds of thousands of new
members last year and particularly a
younger generation that got involved and
I think if you kick does that and we
give our membership a say engage them
say look you know by giving us a few
quid online you effectively become a
shareholder you know in this and they
take policy handsome and we will say to
you we're considering going for this as
an area of policy direction are you with
us are you against us engage them that's
what Grillo's done and it's worked ok
Nigel proj you keep leader there thank
you very much Andy very good to see mr.
price